struggling with constant inflation has
become a part of Amalia rasa's daily
life
[Music]
hermegur's salary as a housemate is
barely enough to care for her four
children and pay for basic Services
it is so difficult lately we are not
buying many things like beef or chicken
that have become too expensive but I
don't lose hope that things will change
so we can all live better
Amalia lives in a very poor neighborhood
in Buenos Aires it is in areas like this
where the impact of spiraling inflation
is hitting the hardest
on the streets many blame the current
government of Alberto Fernandez and the
IMF
Argentina is struggling with over a
hundred percent inflation in the past
year and Rising poverty this country has
had over 20 programs with international
monetary funds it has defaulted on its
debt seven times in its history and
until now has been unable to resolve the
chronic problems that exist in the
economy
Trade union leader overloy says the
problem is that Argentina is constantly
trying to solve its problems in the same
way
the government has died and under the
control of the IMF and the plan for
Argentina is only about increasing
inflation and generating a recession at
the expense of the poor because it
always goes back to implementing
austerity measures
in 2022 the government and the IMF
signed an agreement renegotiating the 44
billion dollar debt former president
Mauricio magri acquired in 2018.
it was the largest Loan in the fund's
history
the New Deal includes an economic
program that Argentina must comply with
in order to receive disbursements every
three months
the problem is that the covet pandemic
the war in Ukraine and the worst drought
in years have further complicated the
economy
making it more difficult for Argentina
to meet its obligations
when you look at the new agreements and
you consider how the agreements have
been in the past it has been much more
flexible and with the war and the
drought all agreements were reviewed and
adapted to the economic reality the fund
today is not the problem and it's not
the Salvation you need to fix certain
problems in the economy
argentines are longing for economic
stability exchange rate controls
constant price changes and economic
hardship are having a huge impact on
people's lives
but the crisis and the uncertainty over
the presidential elections scheduled for
October are unlikely to bring the
changes people here so desperately needs